[Musique]
2048 terre tombale aligner chacune
marque la sépulture nos soldats
canadiens tombés dans les heures ou dans
les semaines qui ont suivi le
débarquement une idée du terrible
sacrifice de la bataille de normandie
que c'est un gros ordre c'est pour venir
leur rendre hommage que j'en tremble a
décidé de retraverser l'atlantique à 94
ans
celle ci pour coiffer les gens tentaient
l'epim officiers ici je me trouve au
projet j'te question là pourquoi eux et
ils en moins le 6 juin 1944
au petit matin ils débarqué sur les
plages de bernières sur mer sous le feu
des bases ennemies 75 ans plus tard la
proximité des champs de bataille ravive
des souvenirs longtemps foule mais gel
de l'aide que mes compagnons qui chante
à elle ces seuils paul avec nogent
[Musique]
alors qu'ils honorent ici la mémoire de
leurs frères d'armes disparu les anciens
combattants savent qu'ils assistent
peut-être à leur dernière commémoration
du genre le devoir de mémoire dans ces
circonstances prend tout son sens pour
que ce sacrifice n'est pas été fait en
vain
en normandie les anciens soldats
canadiens sont applaudis partout ils
vont bien ici les habitants connaissent
le prix de la guerre et la fragilité de
la paix et beaucoup observe d'un oeil
inquiet la réapparition de division en
europe c'est l'exemple que nous devons
présenter à nos enfants pour éviter les
pièges de l' idéologie haineuse porté
par les fanatiques sens moral c'est
également le message qu'a voulu faire
passer la gouverneure générale aux
centaines de jeunes venus de partout au
canada
pour julie payette en ces temps
incertains
nous ne sommes pas à l'abri de nouvelles
tragédies cette bêtise miss meurtrière
que nous apportons les humains lorsque
nous refusons de nous entendre et pour
cela il faut continuer à rester ici il
faut continuer à tendre la main à
travailler ensemble
celles qui ont dit jci a lieu j équipe à
shade nouvelles jantes rampe chancia
mitrailleur aussi se méfie des
idéologies meurtrières
il lance donc un appel à la clairvoyance
adressé aux nouvelles générations chine
toute la manche très intelligent pour
deux chaînes ou deux freins
ils apprennent bien un message qui de
toute évidence atteint sa cible
ici jean françois bélanger radio-canada
au cimetière de béni sur mer